buenos días a las siete de la mañana
abre este centro de votación en el
distrito de columbia en la votación de
las siete de la mañana a ocho de la
mañana precisamente como usted lo
mencionaba acá en este barrio latino por
excelencia de la ciudad de washington
donde viven sobre todo centroamericanos
nicaragüenses guatemaltecos y
salvadoreños pues va a haber una gran
afluencia como lo conversamos
previamente con algunos de los
asistentes que madrugó a este centro de
votación para estar preparado en la
ciudad está bastante vigilada de las
carros de policía todo tipo de cuerpos
de seguridad está rondando el área de la
casa blanca' los centros de votación y
los principales edificios de la ciudad
cuando se camina por el centro de la
ciudad se ven que muchos de los
edificios están tapados con láminas de
madera dado que hoy a las ocho y media
de la noche se espera que en 20 grupos
de activistas salgan a protestar en la
plaza black
la ciudad muy expectante mucha gente ya
madrugando esperando pues sus lugares de
parqueo para poder venir a hacer fila a
estos centros de votación y ejercer su
derecho al voto
así es cristóbal ya hablamos entonces de
a qué hora abren las urnas en washington
la capital estadounidense pero le
pregunto qué pasará con el resto del
país en los principales estados y además
cuando cierran estas votaciones hasta
qué hora pueden votar
aproximadamente hasta las 8 de la noche
cada estado tiene su horario hay estados
que abren a las 6 de la mañana cierran a
las 7 de la noche pero si tuviéramos que
dar y generalizar el horario de votación
acá en eeuu ya desde las 7 de la mañana
hasta las 8 de la noche hay que
mencionar y usted lo decía previamente
que el voto anticipado es cerca ya de
100 millones de estadounidenses
participado activamente en este
ejercicio democrático y han enviado su
voto sea por correo o pues se han
acercado anticipadamente a las urnas hay
que mencionar que hace cuatro años la
votación anticipada fue apenas de 47
millones de estadounidenses esto es
considerando además que se espera que
151 millones de estadounidenses voten en
total en esta elección porque eso quiere
decir que ya dos tercios de los
estadounidenses han votado se espera y
esto es importante mencionarlo como lo
decían ya varios medios de comunicación
analistas que el voto anticipado sea el
voto sobre todo demócrata hoy lo que
están diciendo varios medios de
comunicación es que saldrán a votar
sobre todo los republicanos entonces el
voto anticipado si es sobre todo
demócrata y el voto presencial se dará
hoy que son cerca de 51 52 millones de
estadounidenses sea sobre todo república
todo puede pasar entonces que estaban
muy rápidamente dónde van a estar
esperando los resultados donald trump y
yo valencia que se conoce en la noche de
hoy
exactamente si es que se conoce en la
noche de hoy los resultados finales y
podemos ir a decir que hay nuevo
presidente pues no estará en las casas
blancas y había dicho que de pronto
había planes de que recibieran los
resultados en la florida lo que está
claro en el partido republicano es que
no habrá una reunión en el hotel trump y
por el lado de joe biden él estará el de
la web donde vive allá en su casa
acompañado de asnos y su familia